So tell us about what dynamic parallelism adds to the CUDA programming model.
>> So quite simply, it let's you launch kernels directly from inside another kernel,
and that sounds relatively simple. If you like the analogy on the CPU side is when I could create threads inside of process.
Instead of having to go back to the operating system to initiate a new process,
I can suddenly spawn a P thread and do something asynchronously within the single process that I have,
manage that all from within my own process.
I can now do that on the GPU as well. I can create work and not just single threads,
I create whole grids from inside of my GPU. So if my problem is working on something,
and I suddenly need to invert a matrix or perform a Fourier transform or something,
I can suddenly just call out into a kernel which does that for me, returns the data,
and I can continue so I can embed parallel work exactly where I need it with the data that I have available inside my program.
Sort of corollary to that is this idea of being able to take data that dynamically you are working on,
a value that you have sort of mathematically, algorithmically generated,
and use that value to make decisions on work you're going to do.
If my value is 1 do this, if it's 2, do that.
Or maybe I am partitioning a problem, I am building a tree,
spatially partitioning something.
If I have a certain number of things in one place and a larger number in another place,
I can dynamically launch the correct number of threads to do that,
and the ability to do this on the fly dynamically is really the power of this dynamic parallelism.